♪ ♪
>> Greg: HACKERS ARE BENT ON
TO DISRUPTING OUR LIVES, A MAJOR
MEAT PRODUCER, FUEL SUPPLIES AND
TRANSPORTATION NETWORKS RATE
OFFICIALS ARE TELLING AMERICANS
TO GET USED TO IT WHICH MEANS
THEY CAN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
IT CAN GET A LOT WORSE.
SPEAK OF THE FIRST THING IS WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
THE REALITY AND WE SHOULD ASSUME
IN BUSINESSES SHOULD ASSUME THAT
THESE ATTACKS ARE HERE TO STAY
AND IF ANYTHING WILL INTENSIFY.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT ADVERSARIES
OF THE UNITED STATES HAVE THE
CAPABILITY RIGHT NOW TO SHUT
DOWN THE POWER GRID?
>> YEAH, THEY DO, THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF ATTACKS ON ALL
ASPECTS OF THE ENERGY SECTOR AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR GENERALLY,
IT'S HAPPENING ALL THE TIME.
>> Greg: SCARY AND
JOHN RATCLIFFE SAYS AMERICA IS
FALLING BEHIND IN CYBERSECURITY.
>> THERE'S A GAPING HOLE IN OUR
CYBER DEFENSE AND THAT HOLE IS
CALLED THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, BY LAW THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO DEFEND OUR
NETWORKS AGAINST DOMESTIC
ATTACKS BUT AUTHORITY IS NOT
CAPABILITY AND YOU KNOW,
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK MOST FOLKS
IN THE GOVERNMENT STOPPED
ARGUING A LONG TIME AGO ABOUT
THIS.
>> Greg: SO DANA, THEY
RECOVERED $2.3 BILLION WORTH OF
BIT COIN FROM COLONIAL PIPELINE,
THAT WAS THE RANSOMWARE ALTHOUGH
TO ME RANSOMWARE IF IT SOUNDS
LIKE SOMETHING YOU WOULD PUT ON
IF YOU WERE PLANNING ON BEING
KIDNAPPED.
>> Dana: YOU NEVER KNOW.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
>> Greg: A HALTER TOP.
IS THIS ENOUGH JUST TO TAKE THE
CRYPTO?
SHOULDN'T YOU BE PUTTING IT IN
THE CRYPTO?
>> Dana: YES, SHE BASICALLY
WAS SAYING, YEAH, IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE PREPARED.
WE KNOW THAT, WE'VE KNOWN THAT
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
THIS MORNING ON THE NEWSROOM,
THE GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO PUSH BACK.
SO THE SOUND BITE, ONE, WE DID
TODAY IN TERMS OF GETTING THAT
CRYPTO BACK BUT IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF THE ADMINISTRATION
SAID, AMERICA WILL NOT STAND FOR
THIS.
>> IT'S A DECLARATION OF WAR AND
WE WILL KILL YOU LIKE A
TERRORIST.
>> Dana: FOR YEARS YOU MADE
THE POINT, TERRORISM AND
BIOTERROR TOGETHER, IMAGINE
THAT, PLUS THE WARS THAT WE ARE
IN, I THINK WE ARE IN A CYBER
WAR RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THOSE ARE
ATTACKS AGAINST ACTUAL PEOPLE
AND THAT'S THE NEW WAR WE ARE
ALL GOING TO HAVE TO BE FIGHTING
AND PUT ALL THESE THREE COURSES
AND DO IT.
>> Greg: PUTTING ANTHRAX ON A
DRONE AND LETTING IT GO OVER A
FOOTBALL GAME, IT'S PRETTY EASY
TO DO.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT BITCOIN
STUCK PROBABLY MORE THAN ALL OF
US COMBINED, YOU HAVE SOME.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE ABOUT THIS NEW
KIND OF ACTIVITY?
>> Sean: I'M A HUGE FAN BUT TO
YOUR POINT, I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE AGGRESSIVE, THERE IS A ROLE
FOR OUR BUSINESSES TO PROTECT
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE AND KEEP
THEM SAFE FROM ATTACKERS KIDS IN
THEIR PAJAMAS COME IN THEIR
BASEMENT DOING THEIR THING ON
THEIR COMPUTER, SHOW UP, YET YOU
MIGHT GUESS WHAT?
NO MORE ATTACKS, THEY CAN ATTACK
US BUT THEY WON'T BECAUSE THEY
WILL GET A KNOCK INTO THE HAT
AND I DON'T THINK PUTIN IS GOING
TO PLAY BALL, HE'S NOT GOING TO
HOLD ALL THESE HACKERS
ACCOUNTABLE, THESE LITTLE BAD
ACTORS AND THESE DIRTY LITTLE
COUNTRIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
THEY'RE DOING TO OUR COUNTRY,
YOU SHUT DOWN OUR.
PEOPLE DIE.
>> Greg: THERE MUST BE
SOMETHING PUTIN CAN GET FROM US,
THAT WAS INTERESTING TIMING THAT
THE PIPE LINE ALL OF A SUDDEN
WAS OKAY TO HAVE THE CROSSWINDS
OR WHATEVER, IT SOUNDS LIKE A
CAMPER.
THAT HAPPENED.
GERALDO, IF WE GET TIDIES
ATTACKS TO WHITE SUPREMACIST --
>> Geraldo: YESTERDAY WAS JUNE E
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY, THIS IS
WAR, AS MUCH AS THAT WAS WARMER,
YOU KNOW?
BIO, GERMAN, BITCOIN IS SO
UNTRACEABLE.
IT WAS MADE FOR CRIMINALS, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT.
I JUST THINK THAT IT'S NUTS,
THEY SHOULD HAVE BITCOIN THAT
EXPLODES AND THEY CAN DIE ON THE
HANDS OF THE USERS THE WAY THEY
DO IN BANKS.
I THINK IT'S VERY TROUBLING AND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT IT
AND I CAN'T EVEN FIGURE OUT MY
PASSWORD.
>> Dana: IT'S "PASSWORD."
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ITS "GERALDO."
BVI FEAR FOR THEIR FUTURE UNLESS
WE SET THEM LOOSE TO DEFEND US,
RIGHT?
>> Greg: I NOTICE A TREND WITH
DEMOCRATS, WHEN THEY SAY A
PROBLEM IS HERE TO STAY.
, IT'S THE ONE THAT THEY CAN'T
FIX.
IF YOU SAID TO THEM, "SYSTEMIC
RACISM IS HERE TO STAY."
>> Katie: IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S A GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
NEED TO LEARN TO CODE, THEY CAN
HELP THE COUNTRY AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE GOVERNMENT
NEEDS BUT THIS ARGUMENT OF
SAYING, WE JUST NEED TO GET USED
TO BEING ATTACKED IS SO
ANTITHETICAL TO WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S JOB IS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PROBLEMS
THAT THEY MAYBE WANT TO DOWNPLAY
EXPECTATIONS FOR, THEY SAY, GET
USED TO DOING IT BUT THINK OF IT
AS, IT'S HARD TO THINK OF IT IN
A TANGIBLE TANGIBLE WAY BECAUSE
IT'S DIGITAL BUT INC. ABOUT AN
OIL TANKER, THE COMPANY WOULD
HIRE SECURITY BY THE GOVERNMENT,
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY WOULD
THEN TAKE ON PROJECTS, PROJECTS
TO GET RID OF TERRORISTS WHO
WERE ATTACKING U.S. INTERESTS IN
THE PRIVATE AND MILITARY TARGETS
TO MATTER WHERE THEY ARE IN THE
WORLD.
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE, AFRICA.
SO THE GOVERNMENT HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO FIGHT THIS FROM A
LEVEL OF MILITARY FORCE AND
SENDING IN SOME NAVY SEALS, OR
IT MIGHT SEND THE RIGHT MESSAGE
OF THESE PEOPLE DO NOT CARRY OUT
TERRORIST ATTACKS ESPECIALLY ON
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE HERE IN
THE STATES.
I THINK THE ATTACK ON THE
MEAT-PACKING COMPANY HAPPENED
AFTER IT WAS PUSHED THROUGH SO
IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER UNLESS
THEY ARE FORCED TO FOLLOW THE
CONSEQUENCE FROM THE GOVERNMENT
AND NOT JUST A SECURITY FROM
PRIVATE COMPANY IS GOING TO KEEP
HAPPENING.
>> Geraldo: IS CHEAPER FOR THE
COMPANIES TO PAY THE RANSOM
BECAUSE THEY ARE INSURED.
YOU'D OUTLAW THAT INSURANCE.
>> Greg: THE COSTS AND
BENEFITS, THEY THINK IT'S
CHEAPER.
WHAT IF IT'S YOU THAT IS BEING
EXTORTED?
>> Dana: I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THIS.
BEFORE THOSE PICTURES YOU TOOK
BACK IN THE '90s?
IF A KID GETS EXTORTED IS HE
GOING TO TELL HIS PARENTS?
NO, HE'S GOING TO FREAK OUT, HE
COULD HARM HIMSELF, THAT'S WHAT
SCARES ME IS THAT THOSE THINGS
HAPPEN MORE AND MORE.